I was about six months pregnant with my
daughter and a neighbor asked me Julie
we go back to work after the baby is
born all I could think was are you
kidding me of course I'm gonna go back
to work after the baby's born my
identity was tied to my career success
but it was only a few short months later
I was holding my daughter I don't lie
could think was are you kidding me of
course I'm not going back to work how
was I to reconcile these two identities
how was I going to define my own
happiness I realized then that the paved
road in front of me didn't lead to my
happiness I was going to have to blaze
my own Trail now what do I mean by that
I mean societal norms had left women
choosing between staying at home and
career oriented but I guess I just
didn't see the world is so black and
white and I needed to figure out the way
to my happiness so I've spent the last
13 years blazing my own trail I've
co-founded a company and I've raised a
family and the trail is far from
complete but I've learned a few things
along the way I've learned that first
and foremost you must define your own
happiness ignore the critics I've
learned that creative solutions are
oftentimes the key to success and I've
learned that it's worth it it's worth
the blood sweat and tears in order to
find your own happiness so how will you
define your happiness will you blaze
your own Trail I stand here before you
the experiences of a mom but the reality
is that dad's oftentimes have the same
questions not to mention the need to
love and support the mothers in their
lives
understanding what would make me happy
was a journey I spent long hours that a
hedge fund and trying to balance that
with a family I was miserable and when I
tried to just stay at home I wasn't
content either I needed to find a way
through for a creative solution my
husband and i co-founded a company and
the naysayers that we were crazy to
start a family with a young to start a
company with a young family but they
didn't share my priorities as my own
boss I had to leverage to create value
and a license to pursue my ideas but at
the same time I had flexibility to work
half days and be at home with my
daughter we kept strict rules between
five and eight pm was sacred we had
dinner together and we traveled very
little and yes there were days where we
had to tell clients we simply couldn't
make it to a meeting one crucial and
important meeting we missed in order to
be at our son's kindergarten graduation
as I stand here now and I look back with
hindsight being twenty-twenty my choices
seem obvious to me let me be clear it
wasn't easy we sacrificed company growth
for our family priorities and there are
so many times where I felt like I sucked
both at being a mom and a manager who
are today a student but we stayed
committed to our path now there's a term
for this lifestyle choice the mom
preneur lisa stone rock this model after
the birth of her son much to everyone's
surprise she left her job in the
newsroom at CNN in order to blaze her
own path her creative solution blogger
com now again the naysayer said she's
crazy women aren't going to go online
but she leveraged the fact that she was
a single mom to a one and a half year
old in Silicon Valley to know that this
really was a possibility but this talk
is not about being an entrepreneur
working full-time working part-time or
staying at home it's about knowing if
you keep an openness to creative
solutions the possibilities are endless
so there was another pivotal moments in
my life hi had three school-age children
I was on the verge of selling my company
and I had been accepted to the GSB on
many counts I had accomplished what I
set out to do it was a day before April
orientation and I found out I was
pregnant and holy crap twins as I began
to look up at my new reality I was
prepared to set aside my lifelong dream
of attending Stanford I was a mom I knew
what I had to do and I was prepared to
do it when we sat down to tell her other
children about the twins entrance into
our lives my daughter then 11 years old
looked up at me and said mom you're
still going to go to Stanford right you
have to
so you stand here now blazing through my
own doubts blazing a path is the mom
with the most number of children at the
GSB perhaps ever but but this was my
dream and I knew I had to do it when my
daughter asked me I knew I'd have to
figure out a way to come and I'm here
Teresa Taylor in her book the balance
myth says blending your life together is
really about being authentic all the
time I don't think of myself as someone
with two different lives or two
different places to be this is me this
is who I am I love this notion I
subscribe to it completely my light my
family is a part of everything I do
they're a part of my authentic self so
when I started writing this talk a few
months ago Stanford assign me a speech
coach I knew even then that I wanted to
include my family as part of the talk
excitedly told him my plan but he was
less than enthusiastic but Julie so much
could go wrong and he's right my twins
might get up here and start crying my
teenage daughter she's unlikely to smile
and my boys well they could poke at each
other in front of all of you but how was
I to get up here and give a talk about
integrating work and family while
ignoring the naysayers without doing
exactly that so let me introduce to you
this is josh Helen max Ryan Sam Luke and
my niece Claire without whose help I
wouldn't be here I'm so glad they're
here because I need them and I need you
to see them so now when you see me on
campus with perhaps some avocado on my
sleeve or bags under my eyes you'll know
why but but in this avocados filled
sleepless world I'm pursuing my dreams
and no I don't have everything I miss a
lot of things at the GSB and
occasionally I missed some things at
home too but I'm happy so your paths
won't look the same as mine and okay no
clapping for that part and it likely
will look different than even what you
expect but in those moments when you're
facing the paved road in front of you
and you realize that it doesn't lead to
your happiness know that if you trip
blaze your own path the possibilities
are endless figure out what feeds your
passion refuse to accept can't or not
possible how will you define your
happiness will you blaze your trail
ok